donc je suis absolument ravi que mon premier
livre qui est sorti il ​​y a deux ans en
français
soit maintenant aussi en anglais il
s'appelle l'équation de la connaissance et
il a été publié par crc press
et vous pouvez bien sûr le trouver sur amazon
et d'autres non  -les sites Web
ayant maintenant un livre préféré sont, je suppose, un
peu comme un premier
enfant, même si vous avez peut-être un
favori, ce n'est pas nécessairement agréable de le
dire à haute voix,
mais je serai honnête avec vous ici,
c'est le livre le plus
fondamental que j'ai  'ai jamais écrit et
probablement le livre le plus
fondamental que j'aurai jamais
écrit oui parce qu'il aborde sans doute la
question la plus importante
de toutes réfléchissez-y quelle est la question la plus
importante il y a
quelle est la question la plus fondamentale de
toutes les questions
est-ce que c'est le  hypothèse romaine vraie
ou qu'est-ce que la vie peut-être ou sommes-nous seuls
dans l'univers
ou quelles sont les lois fondamentales de la
physique ou Dieu
existe-t-il bien je dirais qu'il y a une question
beaucoup plus importante
que  toutes ces questions
combinées et cette question plus importante
est de savoir comment savoir oui parce que si vous pouvez
répondre à la question fondamentale de savoir
comment savoir,
vous pouvez utiliser la réponse à cette
question pour répondre à toutes les autres
questions en
tant qu'informaticien ray salomonov l'un
des  les figures
emblématiques du livre ont dit un jour en science que mon
intérêt était plus dans la façon dont les choses ont été
découvertes
que dans le contenu des découvertes
l'œuf d'or
n'était pas aussi excitant que l'oie qui l'a
conduit
et ce livre ne parle pas de l'
œuf d'or il s'agit de la  la poule
aux œufs d'or qui pond tous les œufs d'or de la
science,
il s'agit de savoir comment s'assurer qu'une poule donnée
pondra des œufs d'or et comment vérifier
qu'un
œuf donné est bien doré.
on a tendance à
associer cela à l'épistémologie et à
l'histoire des sciences et dans ce livre
vous trouverez en effet beaucoup de
discussions sur les grandes
idées philosophiques de la pop  e
ou hume et sur la façon dont einstein a défié
newton à
quel point les mathématiques ont été bouleversées et comment
darwin a révolutionné la biologie,
mais tout cela bien qu'intéressant ne soit pas
le cœur du livre,
le cœur du livre est une affirmation centrale
qui a longtemps été controversée
mais devient de plus en plus  plus consensuelle
au moins au sein de la communauté philosophique
et cette affirmation est que la bonne façon de
connaître la bonne approche pour
penser le monde est de suivre aussi
attentivement que possible les
règles fondamentales de la probabilité
comme laplace l'a soutenu il y a plus de deux siècles
cette affirmation audacieuse et fondamentale  est
parfois connu sous le nom de pensée probabiliste
ou bayésianisme en particulier le bayésianisme
s'appuie fortement
sur un théorème fondamental de la théorie des probabilités
connu sous le
nom de règle de bayes car il a été
introduit pour la première fois par le mathématicien anglais
thomas pace de
manière cruciale le livre soutient que la
règle de bayes ne doit pas être considérée comme une simple
curiosité mathématique
c'est plutôt la
règle fondamentale à suivre
parvenir à un raisonnement inductif qui
correspond à déduire des
mécanismes probables non observés à
partir de données observées ou, comme le dirait Laplace, la
règle de base est la seule façon de calculer la
probabilité
des causes compte tenu des événements connus, c'est
la façon de passer des observations
à des théories générales fiables.  c'est pourquoi
je l'ai appelée l'équation de la connaissance
dans le livre, j'énumère un grand nombre de
théorèmes et de
preuves empiriques allant du théorème de james cox à
l'hypothèse bayésienne du cerveau
qui suggère fortement que tout
écart par rapport aux lois de probabilité
conduit inévitablement à un si sous-optimal
pas de conclusions contradictoires,
le livre défend la supériorité du
bajanisme pur, mais malheureusement,
ces lois de probabilités sont
insolubles sur le plan informatique,
ce qui signifie qu'elles nécessitent une
puissance de calcul déraisonnable,
nos ordinateurs et nos cerveaux ne peuvent tout simplement
pas être de purs bayésiens,
nous devons alors recourir à des approximations
c'est le point de départ de ce que le
livre appelle
p  passionnisme ragmatique dont le but est d'être
le plus
fidèle possible aux
lois de probabilité
malgré des ressources informatiques finies je
présente ensuite l'état actuel des
connaissances dans la science
du bayésianisme pragmatique qui est l'une des
recherches actuelles les plus passionnantes jamais réalisées
surtout compte tenu de la  avènement de l'
apprentissage automatique et du big data
et enfin j'illustre tout cela
avec un grand nombre d'exemples
allant des poursuites judiciaires au financement de la médecine et
aux biais cognitifs pour vraiment vous motiver à consulter le
livre j'aimerais conclure
cette vidéo en lisant la conclusion de
laplace
1814 essai philosophique sur les
probabilités
qu'il a écrit si l'on considère les méthodes analytiques
que la théorie des probabilités a donné
lieu à
la vérité des principes sur lesquels elle repose
la certaine logique
qui exige son application à la résolution des
problèmes les biens d'utilité publique
qui sont construits sur elle et les  extensions
qu'il a reçues et peut encore recevoir
compte tenu de son application aux plus
des questions importantes de philosophie naturelle
et d'économie politique si nous
observons ensuite que même dans les choses qui ne peuvent
être réduites
au calcul, la théorie des probabilités permet
aux idées les plus fiables
de nous guider dans notre jugement et qu'elle
nous apprend à nous éloigner des
illusions
qui nous induisent souvent en erreur  nous verrons qu'il
n'y a pas de science plus digne
d'une méditation et dont les résultats soient
plus utiles en
fin de bien